The Android plugin can handle
a large range of use cases, but
it has sensible enough defaults to
make simple builds straightforward.
In addition to handling the actual
business of building and
packaging your app, the Android
plugin provides a bunch of different
configuration and customization
options for us to mess with.
Of these available capabilities,
we'll be covering six main themes.
That Android developers are commonly
find themselves wanting to do in
their Gradle Android builds.
The first is build variants.
It's often useful to build slightly
different versions of the same app,
such as debug version for
testing and a release version for
the Google Play store.
Another common use case is a free
version and a paid version of your app.
The Android plugin makes
it easy to share code and
other common resources
between these variants.
Second, the androidplug in
allows us to manage dependencies
on a per variant basis.
Third, the android plugin
can override resources and
manifest entries also
on a per variant basis.
In lesson four we'll talk about some
of the more advanced features of
the android plugin which
include application signing,
pro guarding and testing